Чи вступить Білорусь у розв’язану Росією війну проти України?
Це питання вже не перший місяць виринає на порядку денному.
Заява самопроголошеного правителя Білорусі Олександра Лукашенка
про створення регіонального угруповання військ разом з Росією
на фоні масованих обстрілів мирних міст України
знову загострила увагу на такому сценарії.
У зв'язку із загостренням на західних кордонах "Союзної держави"
ми з Путіним домовилися про розгортання регіонального угруповання
Російської Федерації та Республіки Білорусь.
Якщо рівень загрози досягає нинішнього рівня, як зараз,
ми починаємо задіювати угруповання "Союзної держави".
За словами Лукашенка, формування такого угруповання вже розпочалося.
При цьому російських військ, за його оцінкою, там буде небагато.
Президент України Володимир Зеленський переконаний:
Росія "втягує" Білорусь у війну.
Росія намагається прямо втягнути Білорусь в цю війну,
розігруючи провокацію з тим, що ми нібито готуємо удар
по цій країні. Опосередковано вона вже втягнула їх,
а прагне втягнути безпосередньо.
Експерти по-різному оцінюють серйозність заяв Лукашенка
і готовність білоруської армії виступити проти українського народу.
Лукашенку вдалося всидіти на огорожі.
Він дозволив Росії використовувати територію та повітряний простір Білорусі
для проведення операцій, але йому вдалося уникнути фактичного введення військ.
Наступним кроком був запуск іранських безпілотників з Білорусі.
Звичайно, українці повинні думати про те, як вони попередять або як вони зупинять ці речі.
Але якщо Лукашенко відправить якісь зі своїх військ фактично
у бій разом із російськими військами, він знає - вони будуть знищені.
Військові Білорусі - десять батальйонних тактичних груп, які вони мають.
Вони навіть гірші і менш компетентні, ніж російські солдати.
І тому він знає, що вони будуть негайно ліквідовані.
Це створить для нього реальні проблеми, більшу вразливість всередині країни.
Поганий рівень підготовки білоруської армії відзначає
і військовий експерт Ґустав Ґрессель.
Існує великий ризик, що білоруська армія насправді до цього не готова.
Внутрішній потенціал опору значно вищий у Білорусі, ніж він є або коли-небудь був у Росії.
Ми це побачили в 2020 році.
Друге - білоруська армія насправді не оснащена
і не організована так, щоб брати участь у таких "авантюрах".
Експерт Фінського інституту міжнародних відносин Григорій Нижніков
вважає, що російська армія готує для себе плацдарм, і розгортання регіонального угруповання
- це формальний привід, щоб знову ввести до Білорусі свої війська.
Експерт прогнозує, що залученість Білорусі у цій війні
буде рости, але поки що без мобілізації на території Білорусі.
Я думаю, що будуть зроблені свого роду деякі кроки,
які вже були оголошені, наприклад, перевірка резервістів.
Масової мобілізації не буде, і я б сказав на це є дві причини.
По-перше, відсутність ресурсів. Не думаю, що білоруська економіка витримає це.
А друге, це те, що ми говоримо про білоруське суспільство,
яке, в принципі, проти війни, а також у своїй масовості проти Лукашенка.
Роздати такому населенню зброю проти мобілізації -
дуже небезпечна річ. Це те, чого Лукашенко не робитиме.
Участь у війні збільшить внутрішні ризики в Білорусі.
А також збільшиться ризик того, що білоруські війська
здаватимуться зі зброєю в полон українцям і будуть з ними співпрацювати.
І це стане ще більшою ганьбою для Лукашенка,
ніж усе, що сталося досі.
Утім, за словами Ґресселя, можливий наступ білоруських військ
або погроза це зробити може зашкодити позиціям української армії,
адже ЗСУ доведеться тримати потужні війська на півночі,
замість того, щоб зосередитись на звільненні півдня і сходу країни
від російських окупантів. Саме цього і намагається досягнути Путін, переконаний експерт.
Джеймс Ніксі, директор програми Росії та Євразії Chatham House,
вважає, що відмовитись від участі у війні Лукашенко вже не зможе,
адже рішення стосовно цього приймають у Кремлі.
Це вже не вибір Лукашенка, Білорусь більше не є незалежною країною,
і він нічого не робить, не запитуючи свого боса в Кремлі.
Але на додаток, я не думаю, що білоруські війська хочуть воювати навіть за свою країну.
І я думаю, що Лукашенку буде дуже важко контролювати власну армію.
Під час віртуальної зустрічі з лідерами Великої сімки 11 жовтня
Зеленський закликав розмістити незалежних спостерігачів на кордоні України і Білорусі,
щоб уникнути ескалації з боку Білорусі
та зняти припущення щодо будь-якої загрози з боку України.